[Music]
gary's with us in san diego to start off
this hour hi gary welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave hi george great to talk to you
thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up
i've got a two-part question the first
is
about incorporating um
sinking funds into the every dollar app
for for budget when you do a sinking
fund versus just having a fluctuating
budget and the second is about market
stability so
i'm
baby step 7
edm
make way more than i spend monthly and
my wife and i have been using every
dollar
i'm consistently but we're really
focused now and there's things like
car insurance things like that
property taxes that are several thousand
dollars that
i'm wondering do you do you set those
aside monthly in your budget or if you
have the money do you just do it every
six months
every year so that's the first part of
my question and then secondly i know
you're friends with
glenn beck and he's talking a lot about
this great reset and everything i'm
wondering if you have any concerns over
the market and alternate strategies like
he does do you have crazy friends
[Laughter]
i've got a few crazy friends glenn's one
of them i love glenn and he's completely
out on a plank i mean he does this every
two or three years he predicts the end
of the world and um i made a rule when i
went on radio i'm not going to predict
the end of the world and if glenn's
going to predict the end of the world he
and i are going to be friends that
disagree
so no i don't think that the world is
coming to an end um
you know if it does then it will but i'm
not gonna i'm not adjusting my
investments and i never have
in any of the crisis and the
geopolitical upheaval that there's been
i've always just kept investing and kept
investing and cap investing and those
the only ones that get hurt on a roller
coaster are those that jump off in the
middle of the ride so george what about
sinking funds well i was just going to
mention on that part on top of uh not
getting hurt on the ride you also kept
your sanity and that's an important part
of this equation you're suggesting maybe
glenn didn't no i'm kidding we love
glenn i'm k we joke all the time he is a
great guy he's a wonderful person i mean
i really like him uh but he just he gets
crazy sometimes man and this end of the
world prediction stuff is one of those
times so i sleep better at night with
that he went off on the gold run a few
years ago getting everybody onto gold
and of course you know i don't do that
so i got a lot of friends that i really
love them and respect their intellect
but disagree with their ideas and so
that's all this is sinking funds let's
talk about that i'll tell you how i do
it my personal every dollar budget and
dave can tell me i've been doing it
wrong all these years but i have a i
have a whole category called funds
that's wrong
i just list them all out and i divide it
by 12. so i pay all my insurance
premiums yearly because it saves money
and so if it's 600 bucks i go all right
we got to put 50 bucks in that syncing
fund category every month and that's
going to get set aside in my account so
that when that time comes the money
comes out and i didn't bat an eyelash
here's the sinking funnel on miniature
savings accounts to cover christmas
because it comes every year in december
they don't move it so you got to get
ready right it's the old christmas club
account it's just built into your budget
as well now gary i do want to that's
exactly how i would do it 99 of the time
i want to acknowledge though that you
said you're an everyday millionaire you
have a huge income you're completely
debt-free on baby step seven so you've
got substantial cash flow what's your
household income
so um
it's different this year so i i'm
retired and my
um take-home retirement guaranteed
income
uh gross is 15 000 a month and i have a
uh okay so if you have a if you have a
four thousand dollar item that pops up
once a year
you just put it in your budget right
so yeah you don't have to save up
you don't have to save up for christmas
making fifteen thousand dollars a month
you can just go freaking by christmas
right got it yeah that's what i was
doing yeah you put that in the budget
that's what you do when you get to this
level now the the purpose of having the
sinking fund is not to nerd out on every
detail it's to not have an expense sneak
up on you that leaves you without food
money that month
because you got oh my god i gotta pay my
property taxes i have no money and i
haven't saved up any to get ready and
they're due you know but in my case you
know we're obviously baby steps seven
people too and so i don't have a sinking
fund for my property taxes i just write
a check when it comes up because i can
fit it into my income like you can gary
and so you don't have to do the sinking
fund but if you've got something that's
big enough
that you experience an algae you know
it's like ah when that when that hits in
your monthly budget then you probably
should have saved up some to get ready
for it with a little miniature
named savings account we call them
sinking funds and it helps to know when
those are coming up because sometimes
you're like i don't know when my premium
comes out every year so it's good to
have that and have the dates but like
you're saying you've got a buffer in the
checking account when you get to a place
like baby step 7 until you're out there
like that i mean when you're in baby
steps one through six and all and you're
still fighting to pay off the house
you're you're still you're not running
with big lumps of cash laying around i
mean you're running it all those ca all
those dollars have names and they're
going everywhere you need to use syncing
funds in that case always
and the classic one is oh i had to run
christmas on a credit card because i
forgot it was in december you know it
snuck up on me like they move it they
don't move it
so that's that's what that's about but
um but man you've obviously done a
wonderful job congratulations gary very
well done